can India become a superpower yes the
answer is definitely yes I given the
natural resources the kind of domestic
savings what we have and the demography
and the skill sets that are available
definitely area can do them a superpower
but the biggest question there is when
then is the biggest question really ND
regulators definitely we need a captive
market competition to step into homework
after that he pulled the domestic
savings and i will put the timeframe of
10 years that is by 2020 being the sea
AVR are becoming a superpower given all
the advantages that we have in terms of
manufacturing in terms of resources in
terms of skill sets hand in terms of
infrastructure developments morbid on
with the special shape